[Music]
hello happy Thursday
Jacob how are you doing Jake I'm doing
pretty good
kind of bummer news today about IO
it is a bummer I that's right in case
you haven't heard the news io is no
longer tied to the Hitman franchise
Square Enix has I mean I guess it
separated them from their franchise
bummer
but we are going to revisit him in a
little bit and hitman everyone makes fun
of me of how I say that hitman I gotta
say hitman I always say hitman oh yeah
it's only one of them not one well we
have to emerge well it's true
any-any anyways ah yeah we're gonna have
some fun regardless in the play hitman
and if you're in the chat and you are
watching obviously you would be uh brain
fart you guys can't help us out we're
gonna smuggle in a weapon and I'm
basically gonna be bossing Jake here
around and we're gonna have some fun
this game is because as you know that's
kind of the way of it
so if you guys have any requests I mean
wow
what do you can't put a sniper rifle in
this one okay so I haven't unlocked all
of the Ivan play this and also I haven't
unlocked all of the safe houses but I
picked the safe as we can smuggle an
item in uh I don't have that many items
either but I do have the sniper rifle
and I do have this machete okay I'm
seeing fire axe I don't I don't have a
fire axe but I think we can find one we
should be able to find one okay um how
about machete
dude we'll do the machete okay
uh yeah we're going I need to take out
those two guys that I picked the the
main mission but we don't necessarily
have to do that we can just kind of mess
around with to Marrakesh with Marrakesh
cool I actually I have not played all
these uh Sapienza and Parris I know
pretty well um so this is gonna be need
me I'm science' and say dad whoa check
this out go with the shotgun do you have
a shotgun and we'll find one time is
obvious I hope we can find one I'll see
if we can find one snipe the guy in the
embassy on the rooftop it's time to go
Emma see on the roof though well we can
do that cool um so here we are we are in
the busy streets of Marrakech there are
a lot of people in this game I always
forget how densely populated it could be
it gets even more populated because it's
a riot going on - oh that's what
everyone is glued to yeah yeah
television oh um and I for played the
snow a while but I forgot where my
hideout is cool yeah you guys have any
I mean again we're gonna toss you around
Jake I'm gonna when we get into a sticky
situation I'm gonna I'm gonna go with my
own instincts which is not ideal it was
going to be a little bit of getting used
to it's been a while since I've played
this yeah we uh we're a little late
today we generally stick to a 11:00 a.m.
stream schedule or try to but we had to
install the game yes this was
last-minute originally going to play
pray but after this news we decided we
should play a little bit of hitman
instead hitman I said it right Rob yeah
um I figure we walk around get a feel of
the area first man this looks really
good on this PC yeah it does I was
playing on ps4 um but yeah this is so
much better yeah I played hope you see
the lighting is very there's an
opportunity opening up this is one of
the main stories to get inside the
embassy and kill the guy were trying to
kill but we don't to go we don't to do
how it tells us that's not fun this is
the riot going on John Luke says
do the Missoula challenge for the guy in
the embassy am i measuring that don't
even know if that ace
um I think the I go through here they
can get mad at me
Oh there no they don't like that yeah I
get that that wouldn't work officer
sounds like dude you don't come on
breath back it up it's the guy who does
the massages massages I I love the sound
of that the guy who does the massage
massages is he in the is he in the like
special cafe or whatever it's good
question how many people care that I'm
lying around in crowbar cuz you know
your bald head and barcode are enough to
be suspicious like that's what this game
is so funny man again a lot of people
are bald in this park that's true
wearing gas masks
he's in the embassy Jang it says okay so
we have to get in there first there's a
couple ways we can get in there we can
help the we can help the the TV crew I
have to find their camera guy I have to
not get their camera guy steal his
disguise yeah you got it
oh we're gonna in this play I want to
see a lot of kills okay so we have to
kill him okay we'll kill him then um so
I think he's in here if I remember
correctly that's not I want to see I
want to see this opportunities here we
go
primetime love it track hmm cam inator
says throw the crowbar to the random
craft unless you have another weapon
well yes I'm private huh damn that was
tight you trashcan oh really so instead
you snuck over I love it here this big
what about some oh this is the guy this
is the camera guy you see desperate to
get a cameraman for an interview with
Klaus Hugo Strandberg so you want to
kill him right we're gonna kill you
every ouch the news oh can you tap him
on the back show does he go the ice so
his thing is that he walks in there
right and I can't get in there unless I
have some dumb pass but there are other
ways in this besides but it's tough to
get in there if I were you
what I'll do is I'll get my coins ready
when defies says go smoke some shisha in
the bar right there I think we can do it
in there I don't know if we can do it
here but there's watch okay that fire
alarm lis up
like this I'm gonna have to ask you to
move a lot of trespassing on you can't
let you through
I'm real sorry the voice acting is
really great nice day for it isn't it
excuse me do you have an invite see I
need an invite
I'll give you an invite oh I saw that
guy's line was so good I just got the
fastest car she gets up in leaves no no
I got him later
oh then I can take out the waiter and
get in a nice neighborhood
I want this guy to go look at my cook it
go to the coin he just turns to me
immediately and he's on you
all my corn bag
you're so cheap I don't know what
currency that is maybe it's worth a lot
we're playing on PC uh gaming cracking
dammit he just looks at me okay I know
how to get the invite I don't know what
settings we have as far as I mean again
we just download this as soon as
possible but I'm running on a 1070 so I
mean for us it looks really great
I don't know if we could have pushed it
to the limit but
what's your playing everything I don't
know can you go there's these or any
other way around
I'll let's look can you circumvent the
building how are you sir
hopefully all Jerry American accent how
are you welcome oh man you're gonna get
oh nice da ting aye Dom you're asked
shadow more doors a good game it's a
real fun game very different this very
different and topic but that I'd answer
him crank it up
alright so I walked around it
oh wait a second wait a second wait a
second oh you could put something in
that bike like a bomb
unlock mm-hmm oh I threw it in should I
get it and break it open is it still
there probably can we someone picked it
up can you go out this way oh okay
unless someone picked up a crowbar and
jacked it I where did I throw it right
over here right I think so yeah oh there
it is yes move get out of the way that's
mine
you can't conceal that no he said own
thing I could conceal a crowbar hi can I
do it cool
you can't conceal like Saul rivals it's
a friend No
that was that so one thing I really wish
this game had that hitman blood blood
money yeah Blood Money had was that you
could you could disassemble rifles and
put them in a suitcase and you could
walk around to the suitcase that it
arrived that's always the coolest thing
it's Reyes it's so [ __ ] cool it is
the ultimate assassin move is to like is
to build a like yeah a sniper rifle on a
corner perch or something
I love the previous executing this will
get you in trouble should we do it crime
noticed oh she's getting help uh close
the door close the door and then maybe
he'll come in and then you can take
whoever maybe it's respectful Authority
yet he's come oh but now I'm in oh
hunted get in the locker can you get
that locker I can't mmm let's just hope
he brings one just himself right all
right there's a hard-ass hey what you
think you're doing buddy
this is gonna go on keep those hands
behind your head down all right give me
your yeah close those doors
I know go out the run oh that would be a
good coffee where that's a big ten-four
you got the wrong man
see what I forgot oh great thank you
what good-looking different days howdy
trooper hmm okay so uh wait that guy
well they're they don't not looking for
you right now do you have they're still
searching so they can still ha ha nice
smell like trash now well that's your
cloaking agent you smell like [ __ ] just
like us got a good work look legit ok ha
ha oh I am ok alright got a high body
son says I don't home master hey I I
panicked I panicked
that's fine yeah I think you're actually
pretty cool right now I I would have ran
it out naked because I would forgot put
on this clothing alright okay so now I'm
gonna go back through that door right
wait do I even now that I've got this
costume don't even worry about that
should I even worry about that guy
camera guy who I was gonna try to
impersonate so I can get inside oh yeah
if you I don't know I don't think I can
get into the embassy is this I can't he
kind of sound like a douche bag though I
kind of want to kill children yeah kill
him we're kind of I'm kind of feeling
like killing people today okay or more
so I'm hiring you as a hitman to kill
people in headband
you're just in my ear just kill that guy
okay kill that guy yeah yeah yeah
although I don't know if I'm going to
once I'm not gonna want to shoot him
with the rifle too loud right yeah
definitely - laughs oh that's the guy I
took his uniform oh my god shoulda
killed him
he's like it's like what will he
recognize you I mean I think that why oh
yeah yeah he will he looks really dazed
okay we'll go we'll go around it looks
like man just if you really think about
what would you do in that situation if
you were him like do with that guy's
doing just standing the alley looking
around in my underwear but no but like
would you would you like try to find
clothing or like I would find clothing
for sure but I guess you'd have to walk
around naked yeah if you can find
anything so pretty crowded area too
everyone would laugh at you yeah it's
basically a nightmare check them now
yeah check out
I thought I could smoke at Vegas not
know I'm not gonna come a closer come
closer close wire pick up soda clean now
we don't need that all right is this guy
cameraman no in seafood looks like the
guy in his underwear is moved mm-hmm
yeah everybody at home they don't seem
to care that I'm here that's a good sign
oh but those guys those guys those guys
are gonna figure me out that's will day
yeah yeah I see that thought over their
head oh that means that they're on to
you or is it because you're wearing
their same unit I forget this game oh
maybe idiot yeah no you need this yeah
they're gonna release no breakthrough if
you need it these don't throw something
over there maybe I could knock out a
waiter become the waiter that's the guy
yeah Markus throw something that that's
why they read they are suspicious
because you're wearing their uniforms
all right uh so I printed levels some
people like some won't and some will
like it's just kind of like I don't know
those are the guys that might know me
you know or know the guy that I knocked
out or whatever okay
know your excuse hmm and then do these
waiters go anywhere like I could
probably debt you knock them out knock
them out here god I'm such a cool thing
if you could just like that okay guys I
speak to you over here can I see you in
the kitchen please they don't seem to
care that I'm just up in their biz
oh this guy isn't leaving though this is
good that's good
oh yeah cuz now you can go on the other
way exactly you're back go across the
pond okay a little wet oh I can't now so
here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna kill that guy and I think the
cameraman has to use the
him at some point he could be it
Oh is the officer in there it's like it
is this might be a [ __ ] show lit open
just take them out to take them out do
it oh no no cuz you gotta close the door
oh oh ha ha ha then you go sleep now my
child this guys coming in good perfect
perfect alright so i botched that no you
didn't that was all he's telling
everyone to leave I'm sure it's nothing
ok but right now we need your
cooperation thank you club membership
card is he I can't get a read on this
guy didn't he just say it's all good and
then he's dying still good relief but
where is the camera guy I think they had
the camera guy leave so now where does
he go I don't know let's find the camera
guy again
King isn't it don't you have like a
sixth sense type thing where you can
like you can like see where he is
doesn't he come up Oh No
think of your targets
Oh quick smoke who's up oh good
no don't okay I hate that woman
hi where's this Audi trooper I have no
idea where the camera should we ignore
him I guess maybe this old no cuz he's
not well he should be highlighted cuz he
isn't argot it yeah targeted him or keep
looking around let's see do that again
just do a little eggsy poison mm-hmm
well there's one guys to kill is the
other guys supposed to kill alright well
I imagine he'll come back
would you miss John Luke well we killed
two people uh called a fellow but we
didn't officers we didn't kill yeah we
didn't kill the douche oh is that him on
the left no that's a bike didn't kill
the cameraman so maybe we should move on
I don't know where did he go into the
event eventually he probably does right
well it looks like these people are
still waiting for their camera guys so I
don't I bet he'd return eventually maybe
I wonder what he's doing right now it
keeps me up at night thing about what
that camera guys doing where was he
before here he's just in this area has
he seated yeah he was just hanging out
in this area yeah you can see my effing
invite except that how do I show it my
invite it's not a silencer I picked one
up my bad sir your bad Oh leave all
right I need to kill this guy oh yeah
you do
all right well how do you do that there
are many of people here there are just
kill them and run to there oh you know
what I think I can do I don't know if
I'll get his attention but I think I can
all right you flood the yeah yeah sick
then go outside and see you guys does it
does it take a while flood whatever we
might we got time I can go around use
Wayne do you have an invite yes I have
the invite I don't know how to shine
I thought it was just a prompt that
comes up maybe it's because I'm holding
a gun mmm yeah
there yeah that's why
you're good yeah I'm for your
cooperation sir nice Oh got me really
wanted that man dead
alright replay damn alright man got a
bit more of a handle on things here it's
good
hello oh pardon me uh okay what should
we go out them out with a crowbar
that guy with a crowbar are you Ben
alright well I think we have a new
target now whoa for the story we have
the same targets we can try to kill
someone else
oh you mean do you know I mean the guy
who killed us laughs oh you're right a
sweet sweet revenge you sir don't mind
me I'm fine
I'm not trailing you you're not gonna do
too well in a second
it's like Tony Stark how you
I like the idea of you flooding that
bathroom again okay and then and then
you knock him out in there that's got to
work yeah
also crowbars key where was that I go
back and get the crowbar
where was that it's uh it's a bit away
really I wonder I want to check to where
my garage is can you knock him out and
then put a cap in his face let's do that
yeah we can do that okay you were mean
you you wanted just to use a silencer I
think you should follow through mmm well
so flood that bathroom and then draw him
in there and I say you knock them out
and get the crowbar first all right fine
that's good yeah some of the chats a
crowbar let's let's own up crowbar yeah
I wonder what their photos and so far it
looks like some kind of stool
a lot of smoke a bad on the lungs yes
you just stand right in it
there's a guy London Gerry
Sian says there's a guy that comes out
of there you can follow him in and steal
his invitation pass I can also just hop
over here and go into the building we
want to but don't they'll point me out
in a second we have so many goals now
but I wish I remembered where that maybe
someone in the chat knows where the
garage is I don't know if I wanna get
the sniper rifle right now though
because I'm like if I walk down with a
sniper rifle in this you cannot be happy
I like how you speak in English yeah
James
Carmichael says knock him out with a new
he deserves it there's a nuke in this
level I have not found in this that
would be an easy way to take out the
target be an easy way to and end the
protest and everything oh man I want
like I have those true all right yeah
that's true someone is saying that like
Hitman's all about trying something if
doesn't work restart or resetting so I
should probably be doing like more saves
and stuff like that but I haven't really
done anything significant so now you
chill blended okey take a hit of that no
I can poison it Oh but to say that's if
I had poison yeah
you know I should leave the door open
action Giancarlo and and I think Peter
2:2 we were talking about like if there
were I mean apparently now if there were
going to be another season to like we
were at a wedding it and we'll just hey
well I had a wedding at the zoo release
goes ooh but anyways he we were saying
like how cool would a hit man level be
if it was like at a zoo
it's like targets like feed them to the
Lions or like we were saying like
you had to like dress up as a gorilla
it's like being like the pit and like
blend in and then grab someone maybe
like there's so many like great ideas
like different places you can go to the
hit man game one that I always think
would be kind of interesting is is doing
one like it like a convention like with
cosplay and stuff like that and you like
cosplay is different right
yeah even like III or something like
that oh yeah oh my god is this is a
flooding can you it's flooding but this
guy doesn't give a [ __ ] does it take a
while I mean it needs to spill out what
what someone turned it off it's so when
use the bathroom
I'm not gonna let anyone use the
bathroom until it overflows there we go
all right
all right maybe they have to hear it
I'll leave the door open well it should
leak out after a while see it's
spreading I think what happened because
right after I did it a lady walked in
and I thought she was going to report it
but it must have not been must have not
have overflown that much so she just
turned it off no we got get him in there
another way as a set that's such a hot
blend in look at that
so nice
[Music]
you can you uh like I didn't even show
his imitation yeah he may have already
been in and out a couple but alright can
you drop a series of coins so I know
this guy falls for the coin thing cuz
I've done it to him before but when I
was doing it earlier he like I threw it
he just looked at me like you dumbass
see he just looks at me but everyone
else is like there's such a weird
reaction for everyone
um alright well I just crowbar the back
door again
do you have an invite shut up I don't
can you can you crowbar him and then run
away and then we'll just find into this
guy's sure I just want to see a crowbar
to his face because he made that
reaction or that taunt oh yeah now you
get suspicious of me like that's enough
white pretty tall ball like look for
that guy it's like what's on a different
jacket and you just lost I love it
hunted postal sam says worth it hashtag
I agree that was worth it
gonna get my nice new suit all messed up
and I suit up garbage smell mmm
it's kind of boring exciting
by the way for just joining us uh Jake
here and I ardeat don't that that last
that's what got me killed last night
we're playing hitman because uh if you
do not know today in the news
square enix is no longer having its
developer IO make this series anymore
and I think people worked I mean it
wasn't it like was it confirmed of the
others yeah it said they were doing a
season two that's a bummer oh all right
now let's move on and let's get in this
building okay um I say should I do a
quick save yeah yeah yeah good call
do you need a new suit I will need one
to get in there I think yeah I'm almost
certain I'm still being hunted though so
I'm a bit worried I'll blend in and
drink this soda this doctor pet doctor
pop nice I feel like a dr. pepper right
now or him that lock-on noise another
big clap to do him and go in the
bathroom Oh or go in that room - right
yeah perfect and the game where the
crowbar to get in damn it do you you
have it okay yeah he's gonna hear it
though that's good you get in there and
then if there's other place like maybe I
should see there's another place I can
go to instead like I can run down this
alley where you go oh another guy is it
a guy hi dr. pop in the face
[Laughter]
that was a can of soda exploded cheap
girls who play with you oh no glad you
say God you saved oh I'm going to see
that oh this is the floors yeah I only
grabbed as many soda cans as I can you
just hold on to him
hi your reminds me of oh my god that's
what is it runs with Wayne's World
highway just nails a car
welcome to Marrakech afterload I mean
this is not even that good of a safe
since I'm already hunted yeah it's fine
all right so scared skies and go in
please okay
I'm hunted but not by this guy uh wait
let me grab some soda cans you never
know when you're gonna need a soda can
or two yes yes we have someone had an is
throwing soda game yeah we have three
soda cans stolen normally this wouldn't
be of issue
oh so go go that room again with a
crowbar or something in like bust I
don't know open it so if I remember
correctly there's a there's a store no
sister well I think it's up here
oh I get it man good job sir just leave
his shop whatever
what's up here
I think there's like a secret meeting
going on here it might be a different no
it is what should I do do it
shy shooter I throw so did her throw so
dad her the only I'm worried about as I
throw so to her I'm probably gonna get
the attention that guard up there
well then he might need as soon as what
a soda for both that's doctor pop can
you do it like just like speed throw to
oh man does the this is a challenge next
you kid
that'll kill him I guess like would I
mean
I'd imagine he's got an arm well I broke
their neck I ran up to him broke their
neck so that's why they're dead okay
make sense I got some Intel from that I
don't know what it is but I was paying
attention it's probably not for tunity
oh well alright so we still want to try
to kill the main guy right he'll
evacuation plan
what is that the security alarm sounds
Strandberg has been instructed to
rendezvous with a team of Zaidan
soldiers at the underground garage
apparently a secret tunnel runs between
the consulate and a shoe shop downtown
this is how the banker plan I don't
follow
one of these things that's our forest
whoa can you get down this could be a
way look at him [ __ ] there's a lot of
not to mention a chance to use the walls
which is fine
all right looking good it's bummer we
ran out of soda this guy I got one more
soda his outfit looks so cozy I would
wear that to bed sure all right save
that so that will make a count later all
right so I get his gun oh I didn't pick
up his gun
so I'm curious if I can walk into the
embassy now that I'm dressed like this
probably not but I think oh maybe I can
just just put your gun away please I can
do that
they get me nervous twitch cough too
much coffee consulate generals
never expected so he beats sorry packing
any soda packing any fuzz fizz you may
now over yet impressive ha ha ha we're
watching the whole thing that's okay
blending is in turn okay
we're inside now what this is all new
is that a soda oh you bet it is so I
think it's only fitting that I kill this
guy with a soda can to the face okay I'm
into it I don't know where he is duh oh
oh he's up there excuse me
you need general uniform to enter the
embassy but you can go to the checkpoint
okay
brother and up hey so what yeah that's
right keep it up you'll make our list
this is a real messy room just take the
police uniform this mission is tricky we
were in the middle of a diplomatic
crisis you don't think I know that
and you're shelling on at the desk
checking your nails there you go
go the record room you know that is
would you like to the record room I have
no idea apparently that's where you're
going to find a police uniform offer him
a drink to the face okay so Sam we have
here this is IKEA tonic small screws and
five sort of smaller okay Oh perfect hey
buddy hey what are you what do you
bought a size ten no oh damn it
he'll come back I'll come back I'll come
back I wonder for whatever he was doing
coffee glass I it's it can be tough to
find poison in this game mmm it's so
great though if I can find something
hello right do it right do it do it haha
get body in the trunk
oh just barely cuz someone is right
outside mm-hmm Wow
lots of security here I'll take the
pistol it'll blend in who are you
I haven't had lunch yet this is making
me hungry keep going okay you let me
down naked silhouette guy so this isn't
a massage killed Estero
oh that's his brother nice imagine how
much more suspicious that would be if I
was walking behind be like guys Sprint's
behind it away yeah yeah just taste it
can I help you oh yeah that guy
recognized me too so I'm just gonna try
these different staircases dang dang
people recognized me
I feel like chat is like the person
relaying you I'm just reading as if it's
like that woman relaying you all good
now disable security cam for first ding
they all seem on to me with this oh I
don't think I've seen you here before
bye oh [ __ ] oh yeah hi pussycat what's
your move yeah get in there
good eye
wait you're not come out where this is
good this is whether time out was a good
PITC okay I'm sorry
yes now do something with his body uh-oh
I thought someone's coming in alright
yeah do something with it
I got a delete destroy evidence what
about his body I'll do his body okay
uh-oh ooh I'll put it in this trunk I
think so
I would make it fit nope no Soph a few
limbs maybe yeah that's why I was
thinking well that's not gonna work yeah
whatever napping on the job I think I
killed them because I didn't have the
option to snap his neck oh no nice try
snap his neck well I did it
typically questions of an answer okay
now what now we go upstairs I know you
have to change your costume now or just
well I'm trying to figure out how I'm
gonna get upstairs here cuz they seem to
be on to me I'm safe
a shadow says no they are not pro or
they're what they not are pros yet no
they not are pros yet I am I am NOT
proud now but I think but I think what
he really means that we will be by the
end yeah so what you can do is a it's
not yeah yeah keep on where you sing so
you can like if you can if you disguise
the camera guy you get in here and you
can like shoot that so when the guys
like giving his interview the thing the
moves just drops on them
the video I saw her like gif or whatever
was like oh whoa Nellie
careful you actually think he might have
buried no sweet holder right there
the one I saw was worried she shot the
Moose you hear a loud crash and then he
goes over and all that happened was the
moose fell and like oh you just crashed
it didn't kill anyone he just crashed in
the middle of the set during like their
live show and they're just like still
talking and there's a moose like
shatters sure you oh you got hmm suck on
that uh-oh oh yeah good don't come in
here do you want to snap their necks and
put them in that from that put him what
there's a bin outside oh I'll put the
put her body in it cool yeah that makes
sense
the reception desk yeah I agree with the
Antonio you really need to change you
Kasich oh no yeah okay oh [ __ ] another
guy come yep do you want a costume
change here it is get out get out of
there geez man I need the gun give me
the gun there we go
oh there's a way up here over here I
wonder if they are moving the target oh
no targets still chilling Cole goddamn
do I look cool in this and is a really
cool beret
sure
mm what should I do
we have them here it's only fitting that
I would throw soda at him the only
problem is I don't have soda but you can
flip him can you flip him over the
railing there I think so but I think if
I if I alert if I do anything to this
guy he's gonna notice and oh [ __ ] good
call
I'm trespassing here Oh what's telling
moose
well how am i trespassing and what
goddamn general or whatever you can I
can't be upstairs as a show yeah I can't
I might have to go back to be in a
coffin no you can't though right
I'm surprised we scheisse tell him we
should just kill him
yeah you should kill him and then just
GTF Oh Oh what about that outfit a
janitor yeah there's someone in here I
can see if I can take this guy's outfit
I don't think so I think he's just like
a dude
kill kill him anyway throw the wrench on
I think I should yeah I know grow notice
oh it's the guy it's him what how should
I kill him oh my god it's him it's him
what I don't know what he's doing here
uh I think you should knock him out
throw the crowbar yeah
[Music]
now what
[Music]
Wester I was kind of uneventful but
whatever can you wear his outfit
no so I have the other one I need to
kill now
unconscious oh I forgot who knows what
body that was guys dead now
okay cool I think should I think you
should probably leave yeah that that
that is yeah
[Music]
nobo I cannot shoot with that it was
walk by the thing yet I can't look at
him he's come on can't be here sir back
to your fave there come in central I'm
at the location now and uh yeah duh
things have gotten things have gotten
messy ha they never knew what hit them
oh I turned that on I like I like I was
body found and that said no it's plural
at this point yeah shoot that moose and
shoot that guy should I lead him under
it yeah absolutely yes do you know it's
a for sure yeah Oh clearly illegal
throwing coins come on you know my knee
is hopping I can knock him out bring him
over there let's do that
oh there's a no you're not going
anywhere who both of them do both of
them get up sprint [ __ ] now all right -
kill her - I've never seen this this
game goes so wrong
are you kidding me it's going so right
yeah it is why is this on slimey name is
the floor exactly not uh-oh oh my god
Oh God he's dead I am I don't know what
to do
they're there just waiting for me out
there
gnarlie Oh poison oh no I can't believe
I thought there was poison sky time he
is on to you what oh not anymore
what all right this is getting sloppy
well [ __ ] you think we gotta get out I
don't know if I can get out and you got
a lot of ammo oh yeah I do and run out
though should I know I'm late I think
he's still can stuff your head
Oh No rip where we leave off
oh did so he did we not kill that other
guy oh I forgot to load again now
whatever so let's just kill the other
guy now the general right yeah okay I'll
come to Marrakech just load back into
the beginning or should I load back in
the other save I don't know I don't know
yeah I don't know how to answer that
um should I start at the beginning then
to kill this other guy sure
no it's due from here just it from here
this is the beginning I thought you're
saying like reset the whole thing yeah
it did reset I can reload if we want to
know now we're good okay what this guy
is away from the other
the embassy so it shouldn't be I mean
it's hard but I don't remember being
asked
what should we do so you all get
involved so it's that ways right like
you you pretend or you're a massage
therapist right or whatever and you kill
them like that oh so I would imagine or
that's one of the ways you can put or
know how more well Ian of you are you
suggesting that I represent an
impressive hey buddy
I'm up to nothing missing scoot are you
good
oh wow look at you oh there's nothing in
here
nice Oh
hopefully no one saw that okay the guy
behind you right
now this is hitman yeah look at that two
people respond there's nothing you can
doesn't look like it isn't anything new
if you just stood next to me where his
buddy was damn nothing so these guys
won't wreck just a salute to get this
book oh now here here's a spot I could
hide a body easiest gig in town what
[ __ ] I forgot to leave the all excess
key card in the garage
you're kidding is he gonna go through
there get back there before EXO tears me
a new one that body is gonna be picked
out fast
oh yeah no he's thinking the tunnel Wow
follow him which one which one was
Tatiana
it's the tunnel wait dude do your spidey
sense can you see where the other guy is
yeah he is that way okay but but this
tunnel I think should if I get nowhere
it should put me out closer to them if
we want to do that or I looks like yeah
I'm looking the map looks like it does
like a roll up there we should do about
this guy first let him he's a bad was
Heather's day yeah all right go Oh see
if he knows he's gonna see what should I
do about this guy that yeah crowbar you
throw at him or our soda of a hammer
that works actually he doesn't even
right I could just walk up to him and
just clock him in the face how's it
going
Oh hammer order okay now what I can hide
both these bodies you can put two in a
locker yeah I think I think you fit - I
think you're right sorry dude there's
definitely enough room for two
I don't want to do that bull
all right
that guy recognized me that's a shotgun
didn't someone want a shotgun all right
I don't remember that oh yeah I was way
on this guy ready reading here
should I bash him yep I guess I'm Walker
ready it's gotta be something here whoo
mmm-hmm let's keep moving I want to grab
that shotgun there right Lele will they
be suspicious cuz I would be yeah just
do it e oh I didn't oh is it because you
have are you know it's cuz I was
grabbing the wrong thing sir oh I didn't
want it
but is it because you already have a
like a two-handed weapon nope yeah you
dropped something hahahaha thank you Oh
God
shoot so clumsy today I'm worried he's
gonna see the body
it's a samo lethal poison pill jar and
you need that you're goddamn right we
want that that's very private huh huh
what should I do about this guy I know
that's why I passed him all right we've
been doing a lot of that so soldier that
is me soldier kill those guys you down
yeah bodies are gonna get spotted what
is
you made most impressive 47 now to
locate Klaus Stromberg oh we're back in
the free n we're backing up underneath
the embassy oh really
turn around
that's okay we've got I mean this thing
is like getting there no problem don't
think they think they think dainty
hopefully no one sees him huh what are
ways you can extract out of here like
helicopter and stuff yeah there's a
couple we can't extract on this we
complete both unless we'd do both the
hits okay well then we'll just call it
up that hit then yeah
like leave the building or something
okay
not a good idea that's a horrible idea
well if I had a screwdriver punctured
that before and killed that guy you dude
you know that's a possibility
it is why oh it is okay I all I mean I
assume it has to be right
like he throws a cigarette on the ground
and then oh I love it because he can't
smell a fan so cool okay school's right
up here
whoa nice park job yeah guys a lot of
turret gun has a lot a lot of guards oh
cool
should I save and do it yeah I like to
see it we are playing on PC Scott
Thompson
guys like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] they're not
gonna find you right they're searching I
mean oh my god we're good though we're
good right
man I got nothing to report for my
current location over my weapons hot
I just need to watch out with the guys
with dots over their head like that dude
all right so where you going now in
there Stan yeah
keep your eyes peeled this might not be
over
understood
I'm looking around to see if anyone had
keys but it doesn't look like it
damn that wrecked you Oh God
now to locate generals they dan no one's
known here's on alert no one's worried
about the fact that that just misfired
in yeah do you guys hear that
[Music]
this reminds me of like what recent Bond
movie was that real agent says the man's
treason that's all he's chasing that
dude
that is a horrible way to narrow down
I'm talking about uh there's some day
see any ends any like he he's running
out of the building I think it's like a
UH this looks like a school or something
he runs out he's like got the gun of the
guy's head and like there's a whole line
of soldiers and he like shoots the blows
oh noes Casino Royale that was yeah that
was first one yeah this is the beginning
of Casino Royale was right after that
like I were the first time seeing that
chasing like holy [ __ ] is general raised
as they done keeper of the peace
all righty so that's who I need to kill
mm-hmm you got the window here I can I
think I want to say Quantum of Solace
but I think you're probably right
so how should we kill this guy who has a
narrow ledge um I have some proximity
mines whoa yeah I picked him up except I
can't use any of them all on the ledge
obviously do you know where he goes we
can figure it out I'm afraid to go
through though because they're both
going to recognize that I'm an impostor
there's a really cool way to kill this
guy he's interrogating a hostage and
what you can do is you can knock out the
hostage and be the honey the hostage and
he comes up to you to interrogate you
you like pull out a knife and stab it in
him or like break his neck or whatever
that's cool it's pretty cool
Oh mirrors work in this game good me
mm-hmm oh he's moving sorry gone he's on
the run what if I put a proxy machine
your business oh oh
window window oh god you've got to check
on something guys sorry whoever says
pussycat seriously God keeps yeah do you
see the guy who is like he crouched down
probably goodbye right now though I can
do this
oh oh I know oh now they're fine they're
just like what the hell get out oh man
he is so close
should I just throw a proximity bomb
over there oh it's a remote expose it's
not it's oh it's a rule that's easy
better yeah it is go back to that first
room if I can get there next thing you
know they'll have them at the grassy
knoll wouldn't that be something I want
to say that gives the guard that
recognise you Oh hot dog I'm going to
predicament here and a little bit of a
pickle there they go done
you hop down sir some vent
mm-hmm oh [ __ ] no bad idea
would you got crouch oh yeah he didn't
see that at all the soooooo happen Oh
her Oh perfect
I am pretty sure he comes in here grab
that wrench it came yeah I can't what's
that what's that on a table over there
looks like a brother proximity bomb huh
uh-uh nope it's a toy tank all right
just go through oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
mine there right there yes yes
definitely gonna see it though closer
just do it oh boy wake up yeah I now get
out
I did I did oh I'm dead it's no way I
can get through here quick enough well
that's fine well we're gonna wrap it up
there yeah we killed both of them not in
one run but had some fun that was fun I
had a good time um thank you guys for
watching and putting up with us um cool
yeah well I guess to wrap it up for a
while yeah thanks for watching we're
gonna be streaming a lot now right yeah
we are streaming every day at 11 a.m.
yeah it was a little late because we
wanted to install this but check him
back yeah I think Thursday's have been
my day recently with Peter nothing
against you J that was fun
thank you for playing but yeah I think
you know you're gonna probably play a
lot too right I think so I don't know
what day yet though yeah we're trying to
like assign days but again thank you
guys for watching and have a great rest
of your week
see ya see ya
you